who be welcoming president or a CEO
kuratas on his first speech as his first
arrival as president of Paraguay to the
United States so we're very very honored
that he has chosen Columbia University
as the place to make his opening opening
remarks as paralyzed new president so
can we thank him first of all for coming
today president cartas was elected in
April and took office in August so he is
at the start of a very exciting
administration in a very exciting
country he himself is relatively new to
politics because he's a leading business
man and an entrepreneur in Paraguay a
very successful businessman especially
in the food industry and in many many
ventures and he entered politics
relatively recently on the theme of
Paraguay having tremendous potential to
realize its aspirations of economic
development and ending poverty and those
are the topics that he is going to be
addressing us here today we've just had
a chance to meet briefly before this
you're in for a real treat the president
is very dynamic and very inspiring and a
obviously a great leader of a country
that is determined to make tremendous
progress we are extremely pleased that
we have a number of students from
Paraguay at Columbia University I think
many are in the front row raise your
hand please welcome and we're
in our work with the government of
Paraguay during the past year led by the
volley columbia center at columbia law
school and the earth institute we had
help of wonderful pair of white students
and do we know the the highest quality
that your country offers so we're
absolutely delighted without further ado
please join me in welcoming president
covetous muy bueno SI es a motel good
morning and thank you very much it's a
real honor to be here and I I accepted
on behalf of all the young people in our
country I'm really feel very moves
seeing so many young people here I know
it's the health in the future of our
country and so many compete riete of
mine who are here in Paraguay over to us
seventy-five percent of the population
is under 30 years of age and I always
use a phrase I have three children what
I want from my three children and I want
the same for every young person in the
world the same wishes for my children I
want for all children and our young
people in the world I always said if a
country doesn't have a motivated use
who wants to advance you know that young
people can be old but when young people
aren't interested in anything when they
lose interest in everything what
happened for everything that happens in
the country what they can do for their
country then they can become old even
though they're young I'd like to ask all
of you here at this prestigious
university you have a very ardent and
very motivated young people who are here
and that's very important in the world
I'm really i was telling his Excellency
mr. sex who was in paraguay not long ago
I met him he had been hired for a very
important aluminium financial study
project and for a trade in and important
treaty which we have with our
neighboring country Brazil I'm going to
talk a little bit about Paraguay but as
I said
in the prior meeting that we have I
believe countries need to speak for
themselves by themselves they always ask
us to go around and talk about our
country seller countries I don't think
countries need to sell themselves I
think they need to just present
themselves and show their attractive
points and I believe Paraguay seen a
transition right now and I'm taking
advantage of fact I asked mr. Sachs what
did you think of Paraguay he said it's a
fantastic country and there was a
colleague it's a little country and I
mentioned there to our colleague it's
bigger than Germany and he laughed
paraguay is very tiny when you compare
us with the two neighbors we have
Argentina and Brazil but we aren't
little I love Germany because of its
discipline and work ethic it has 84
million inhabitants we just have a six
and a half million inhabitants we're a
country which is unfortunately we have
to talk about our strengths and our
weaknesses we can't been immensely rich
we explored richness end poverty we
export Argentina to the u.s. a little to
Europe and the main point of our
administration is to fight against that
poverty I call it the devil's equation
forty percent of poverty in a very rich
country well we have ninety percent of
our land which are not able cultivable
we're talking about
as I spoke we said to mr. Sachs before
when he visited what we have everything
that everyone anybody could want you
know the only thing that we don't have
financial resources aside from that
Paraguay has everything the world one
what do we have the best land our fresh
water that we have some of the best most
highest quality fresh water in the
universe we have energy which is
absolutely necessary clean energy we
have caracal and we have two great dams
type rule and another one you rich
borders with Argentina and probably more
which will be produced with in Paraguay
what are we missing opportunity and
resources the word that I have and that
yours you have studying at this
wonderful University how do you know how
it sounds to people outside who when you
say you study at Columbia University a
lot of people are very envious take
advantage of it over your study and I
want to speak especially to the young
people I want to talk to them about my
country I would like to speak like an
older brother a father I want to give
you numbers but that you can are
understandable I want to speak to you
because a great honor to be in front of
you and it really motivates me and I
don't want to leave without telling you
that the president of the public is
wants to achieve everything he wants
this wasn't what I had been dedicated to
but with them people dedicated we can
can achieve this
there's no powerpoint presentation okay
this morning I was with prestigious
businessmen from the US and all over the
world and I had to talk with them about
ours and dimensions as a country I don't
know how to convert it over to American
measurements in square miles I don't
know how many square miles you have to
divide by 1.6 or something right we have
the energy that we have the very few
inhabitants we have a great opportunity
for work and Paraguay has been a
forgotten country for a long time in the
as far as the world considering us and
today I think it's really impressive
within the world's focus everybody is
observing Paraguay as a country full of
opportunity and from the point of view
of our administration we should not let
these tremendous opportunities presented
the Paraguay pass us by accesses to
credit money the possibility I want you
to know that in paragua there's it's
exactly in the center of South America
they call us the card of America but
certainly our heart which is impeding
the hardest impeding yet in very shortly
we're working silently but with the best
people in Paraguay and I say this with a
lot of pride I'm really proud of the
cabinet and several of them I here with
me today it's the most honest cabinet
that the Republic of Paraguay has had in
a very long time and we're working with
the greatest honesty and transparency
which our country so much needs and to
add that there's so much enthusiasm in
Paraguay that many people are working I
wanna without charging just not even one
dollar there in the dark without anybody
knowing about it with the great desire
that Paraguay can take this great step
forward there's people in the country
and outside are very hopeful young
people like you talking out in a broad
prefer to return to Paraguay making me
making less money but following a new
path which the country is going to now
be able to have we have a great
government I pray God that it was he
will give us all the wisdom for each
decision and determination that we make
that will be correct because we've lost
the great deal of time and today I want
to tell you a sentence which my father
always said to me for me everyone has
the right to choose the country they
like best in the world I'm should be
very honest with the country has it that
they've always shown me as that example
is the United States but but as a
country of opportunities with a brother
in an aviation school over here in Tulsa
Oklahoma an aeronautical school here my
father was concerned that we were gonna
stay and live over here he wanted us to
study and then return and he was half
right I'm one of my brother's got
married he stayed here he was wrong in
the other half I went back to Paraguay
because I missed my country i miss my
country and i cried i said a lot of
times i was crying missing my country
because even though a lot is missing
there even now it's a country it which
is very difficult to describe the most
beautiful loving warm people in the
world and it my father was worried what
are you gonna do over here in the US
everything's already done and Paraguay
everything has to be done still and
still there is part of that situation
there's still a lot remaining to be done
in Paraguay because unfortunately as we
said before it's a country with so many
opportunities which I'm really tying you
I don't want to tell you to go in invest
in Paraguay I want you to monitor
parable I want you to monitor my
administer see how we're doing and
that's fight against poverty how we're
doing with our infrastructure how we're
doing in opportunities for our young
people and I'm pray to God honestly that
one day
you will come and visit this country
which today we are announcing on the
microphones that come to visit it
because it's a country which sells
itself it's so attractive and I know
that it has all the attractive point
that I'm telling you it I would like to
tell you what are we as a country as far
as producing food and alimentation
Paraguay has there a very important
numbers we're in fourth place as in the
world exporting soybeans we produce corn
wheat everything which the earth allows
because it's a country we don't have
volcanoes we don't have earthquakes
tsunamis no unfortunately we can't ski
but we can produce things with our land
all year round lots of time we we value
our freshwater and sometimes we misuse
it it since it's a country which has all
the necessary countries to triple its
agricultural protection and its food
production in paralyzed we had a record
production in grains our own record and
where you can even increase that further
as a country and as far as attractions
we can produce what the world is
requiring today which is foodstuffs and
food products we have clean energy and
renewable which is produced by the dams
the only thing that we are missing is
the fight against poverty we did all
this wealth I would want to invite you
to follow up on a way to know it because
it's a country
that I believe that there's a lot more
of a you have read and read about it the
other day international organisms know
about this but I want at the heart of
every young person so we had the best
person the world our power young guys
and girls are the most loving and
objective for the world thank you for
everyone and I'm here ready to answer
any questions you may have I would
invite people to come up to the
microphone I'd like to ask the students
first whether one of them would like to
ask a question before I point to you and
ask a question because this is a good
opportunity for you to meet meet the new
president and ask a question of concern
to your country we also are very lucky
to have the cabinet leadership of the
country with us also foreign affairs
finance and other sectors in the
industry and commerce and industry and
so this is a tremendous tremendous
opportunity maybe i will start but i'm
inviting people to come you guys first
so get your questions together mr.
president what why do you think that
Paraguay has been held back from
development over recent years now
there's some progress starting why do
you see this chance as being a good
chance for a take off of the country so
you cumin seed ok L potential de para
why
that the potential of polymer has always
been there I don't want to talk about
wasn't done yesterday but being very
proud on what we do without a question
what we need is transparency in public
affairs and we are going to fulfill our
commitment that we had a campaign that
everything that is public should be
public and there is and there is no
other adult that it their fight against
poverty and improve the quality of life
of their a lot of money has been thrown
around for them it wasn't the best way
to do it but I am sure that even today
during a breakfast we had eighteen
percent of a stream poverty and they
were asking us that we should have a
target of reducing poverty one percent
per year and I was saying that we should
have higher figures not for a political
challenge but but but the wealth that we
have depends on the energy we applied to
achieve it para wife had made a
commitment with the world in the
Millennium objectives that we will
reduce the extreme poverty from that
that I was an 18-point a percent in year
two thousand and today we are eighteen
percent in 2013 we have two more years
have another we are going to reduce it
by fifty percent that we had committed
in two thousand but we are going to
apply there are almost energy to do this
because there the wolf is there
success what are the lessons there for
making a more general dynamic business
community what we have talked in the de
young people we have a quality of land
that did it that everybody in 10 days
most of the lot of the country are I
have to produce food food stuff some
years ago we had a few areas that were
not a prepared and because of the lack
of technology that was they the Low
Countries they will are flooded but
today they're great producers of rice
which is a high demand in those flooded
in the low country we are doing
producing soya beans and corn and during
the winter wheat and sunflowers and
other things so what we have today is a
lot of land that is nothing worked and
we have to we have to teach them how to
prepare the land it let them know what
we think should we produce and be an
also from a commercial point of view
develop their markets an unusual
circumstance because most of the world
is struggling for how food supplies are
going to go up where is the land
countries in Asia with huge populations
on tiny land and the president was
saying earlier when we met that and now
explaining a country the size bigger
than Germany with the population that is
less than a tenth so a vast land area
water arable climate and something that
we very much care about at the Earth
Institute which is that all of the
electricity is clean zero carbon so this
is also something quite remarkable
because it is hydropower
and it's a largest hydropower project in
the world we've been working on e type
who as you know mr. president maybe you
could explain a little bit about the
significance of the electricity sector
or how you see that in the future as
helping the the overall development and
then I'm going to turn to the students
and ask for their questions in spite of
re of the station land and the quality
of the lands and and the under climate
which provides the this potential to
produce a foodstuff the largest the
largest dams in the world is it a poo
then we have also garage and they have
to eat I Pogo Russell and another 10
thousand dinner and we have to develop
yet a small turbine that energy agua so
we believe the machinery and we have to
add three turbines to deserter and there
is a dam which is spending with
Argentina in corpus that's just the same
size as a senator what do we want to do
with that that's the largest stock that
we have and we have to look at the
country not as an as a cash-generating
engine that but the state has to be a
tool to provide satisfaction and
benefits to its people what we are
convinced is that that what we have to
do is transfer that energy in the
largest amount of and of all employment
positions in the country
because we are not finding that a lot of
people is not finding some pertinence a
lot of companies are coming there
because the tractive of the electrical
costs we have an energy that even asked
the prevalence don't don't value it and
other countries when they find out the
cost I'll surprise another countries
don't even have that energy at that cost
so we should value more what we have but
especially the main direction that we
have to this in men's wealth that more
than a Paraguayan success Mora our God
gift is clean energy that doesn't
contaminate our obsession of all
administration is to transform the
energy in employment for our people yeah
por favor por SI PA pagar la Ramee
tripura percentage mismo have an
overture how you
hi Alison but wait two years I
understand their beauty that you are
describing and this so difficult to
describe and very much interested in the
subject but there have been lately a lot
of of inequality and distribution of law
of the land how do you propose to to
resolve this giving opportunities to
everyone especially for the young people
so that they have access how do you
propose to solve it
I believe I believe what you I really
thank you for what you have said that
this a beautiful country we have great
people is a great commitment because
there's a null depth of the different
ministrations the delivery of land
titles I'm Alan owner I'm talking
without my friends I tell them that is
very important to provide a property
title to land because for the self
satisfaction for the recipient but they
just the title and we are trying to
deliver five or six thousand we have we
have indeed so they should disorder with
the worded property deeds are duplicated
and so we had to do a lot of research
work and and cleanup work but what we
want is we have an old debt with
operation if it were a person a personal
decision I wouldn't even charge but but
it's not that but for so many years we
have not fulfilled our obligation with
him with the less and I would but it but
but also not only that there should be
preparation of the soils discussed
agreement on the products to all the
produce to be produced etc thank you
bienvenido a university Columbia is
gonna win a fragment alessia i remember
i clarify let me first clarify that if i
offended or bothered in you I ask your
forgiveness once and 10 times but it's
not words in a whole bunch of situations
one says one thing and sometimes I'm in
the press it comes out twisted or chains
I'd like to take advantage of the
opportunity I have three children in the
oldest is 29 studying he'll be 29 on
november eight he's studying in miami he
they asked what would you do if they
your son came and said that he was gonna
come and marry someone with the same sex
and I said I would die I would like to
take advantage of your question i would
say i'm a man who has his convictions
but I accept that each person lives as
he or she wants we all have our rights
and everybody has a right to his or her
own decisions and freedom
ask you you have haven't spoken what you
foresee in the future for the guy your
country and for the work perspectives
and where you're working on the
reincorporation the complete wing
corporation for paraguay and medical
sewer and is this necessary so that
paraguay can progress considering that
then paraguay can some bilateral
agreements with other countries and
Mercosur will serve to be able to help
your country advance first of all during
the breakfast maria dare enrique
inglesias was there a personality who
said that every time that my countrymen
speak about the fact that they want to
lead medicos silver I feel like dying
i'm going to give you an example
personally I understand when people make
me graphs or with arrows I understand
more quickly in it the European Union if
it only had that power if we if we go as
a common market we have more power as a
region and the conditions will be very
different than if we negotiate
individually as countries Paraguay has
always negotiating and asked and that
there be respect for sovereignty for
countries that do not belong so that
they were our Constitution be not
interpreters applying to other people a
few days ago the President of Argentina
was in the country and I spoke to her
I told Christina Fernanda I don't want
my country to continue exporting poverty
Dorjan Tina my people my young people I
want them to have the opportunities that
I had in our country my second big dream
I would love that a lot of families I
know what the pain that a lot of
separated families have to go through
because they can't find opportunities
within our own country yesterday I was
with compatriots who live over here in
New York fellow countrymen and I'm going
to tell you a painful but true anecdote
in Spain but they would ask the same
question too despite not having found
the opportunity to work in our own
country they come over here to the US
and to Europe and especially Spain and
sometimes a person will pass away and
they can't even bring that poor the
front person that bought it back to
their own country exporting poverty is
very painful and yesterday we were
speaking with the president of our party
the Colorado party and he said we need
to take care of this inverse of it in
our Parliament and and no negotiating as
an individual is very different than
negotiating as a block and secondly to
specifically answer your question what I
liked in my first appearance at a summit
una sewer in surinam is that even though
we may think differently we are we
should all continue working and making
the effort to do things as a region
thank you
good morning first I'd like to say thank
you for coming today and speaking with
us I'm Marisa I'm as a college student
here at Columbia and before I I lived
two years in paraguay in i was a
volunteer i lived in a very small town i
worked in the education sector and years
speaking a lot about opportunities and
but the young people i would like to
know what is necessary to improve and
strengthen the education system Millie
son Marissa Marissa it done i snooze you
worked for the Peace Corps yes first of
all we have to have and we make the
decision to speak well about Paraguay
and talk about our weaknesses and we're
in have a big debt win are as far as our
education system I was speaking this
morning about it probably education
doesn't have the same cachet and the
same amount of impulse for a government
because governments come and go but
education systems last for the a long
time we believe that if Paraguay lost
and went backwards a lot it was in the
area of Education but we're committing
ourselves to recover as much as God will
allow us to they were as long as people
it hurts
people go and do cleaning John people
work on in construction building
highways manual labor at the same time
in Paraguay a lot of young people are
coming who are educated and they're
finding jobs in Paraguay and that shows
us that what we're missing is people
with prep rakesh and preparation with
sufficient education now we're paying
for what we forgot about yesterday there
are jobs in the private sector because
there are a lot of opportunities there
at the same time the people who most
needed are leaving people with more
skills are coming to the country if we
if we didn't understand before that
education is the most important thing in
our country I'm convinced that a
country's growth limitation is called
its education system that's where we're
going to start I wanted to clarify you
we were elected april twenty first we
have five years eight and we we have
five years to work on this so we're
going to try to finish everything we can
with projects and then with projects
would take a longer period of time at
least initiate them
thank you for coming my name is Shilo
we're very happy that you've come to our
country I know that you spoke a lot in
your campaign about trying to improve
the poverty systems what are you trying
what programs do you have to try and
achieve that goal to reduce the poverty
every you were working in reviewing the
e tapu numbers I comment dead remember
that I a mentioned that young
paraguayans like you who have very
important jobs outside of Paraguay made
the decision to return to Paraguay one
of them today is in the main place for
the fight against poverty which is the
depth planification secretary was in
moline Molina's was working in the World
Bank I met him it's curious in
Washington he was a young leader and now
so that we can offer that him to come
and work in Paraguay just one dove
doesn't one bird doesn't make spring and
I we're never really we're trying to put
in practice having all the different
ministries work together and support
each other it's very different if we can
work between institutions with
multi-person disciplinary teams and its
president I am extremely happy when I
speak with the ministers and they the
Education Minister Public Works industry
and commerce secretary that we're
complementing our work very well between
the ministries and that's going to be a
huge difference
in the case of jose molina is combating
poverty he's using a structure of hours
in the private sector I'm not saying in
a happy way but sadly I know paraguay
which has training and and in
instruction for people who report its
technology for example we use GPS as
long as I see the administration's I'm
not in the right place people are being
trained and in the correct places so
that everybody can work jointly together
so that we can achieve our goals my name
is Emil invalid and 27 years old you
open para why mr. president you
mentioned that paralyzed have plenty of
opportunities a man asking whether the
opportunities for us young investigators
to go back to our country and the second
question which how important will it be
for you and the priority of science and
technology in parable
I I won the election and I have a great
support from the country and also
outside of the only party and we have a
historical member in votes we never got
900 votes in Jenna and we always got 1.5
mm and what was new that in spite of
having a party the husband attacked and
was not well consider for many I can
tell you with a lot of pride than most
of my in provident came from there and
that makes me feel from the that that
deep and that from the letters I get
from youth sometimes they call me uncle
or teal so something the difference is
how you are appointed is not it's not
because you get a position that because
you are a friend assignment but because
of your own values we are doing in the
technological field we are telling them
be ready because we are going there my
name is andrea from chile i would like
have a like leave you could explain a
little more in depth with what you mean
by the production the development of
production development so how are you
going to achieve this to have to have
full a full kappa sites for your own
population a great deficit that we have
totally palaboy i'm going to tell you
about paraguay and we are insisting in
not information internal affairs but we
have a lot of underfed people and it's
very painful in the country is terrible
that we produce that we are producing
food stuff or 80 fullest of sufficient
for 80 to 90 million persons and we have
this level of malnutrition country in
October will have in Panama meeting
where apply and next perception chili
told me Carlos levels see told me to
tell me since you are new what are you
going to present and we're talking about
offering a poet's get up feasible
brazil is the first producer as
Argentina's the third paula y is 4 or 5
4 40 50 name well producer or grains and
and we even understand that we cannot
serve as one of your of your of your
objectives is to is to end malnutrition
and eliminate and eliminate the early
infant mortality or early infant
development because the lack of proper
nutrition will affect their brains but
I'm sure that a weeper poor any we we we
said this this objectives this is
something that we can get because the
food stuffs are there and that will be
my presentation in Panama in the first a
pan-american summit there so we have a
serial malnutrition population Thank You
mr. president my question is best is
related with it abou
and since this is good for the
environment but at the same time but how
your administration is proportioned to
but to keep the indigenous rights within
an agenda within this agenda which are
really this is a mess this is a
difficult question I will make I would
like to meet but I've made this public
before I came here that that there is a
symmetry between colors or among
hundreds our administration favors
looking the best relationship with all
the countries in the world and
especially with our neighbors because we
have to live with them the persons may
change with the regions or countries and
change and there are so many common
interests I'm very optimistic
that both both endeavouring president's
call me they came to us on Theon when we
were showing we shall be lateral
meetings and I prefer being very
optimistic because of the number of
other attractive derived from sitting
together and tell you and tell you what
I told both present the people of our
countries will remember us better
because we are just like a like a like a
rain like a very short period in the
political level country and I'm sure
that our people are going to are going
to are going to be happy with our
understandings and then for our
differences so so this effort and
calendar we can go to move this to the
field of dialogue and reflection in
common not only for para why are only
going for another country I'm I
understand that if we discuss and put on
the table through reasons we should be
able to find better results in benefit
of all of us thank you
I think this was a great demonstration
of all of these linkages your cut
students from Paraguay neighboring
countries students who have worked in
Paraguay students who are interested in
coming to do work in Paraguay and do
research and so I let me take the
occasion and thanking you to say how we
hope and we'll plan during your
administration to build these
connections even more closely and do we
at Columbia University will forever be
grateful that you have opened your trip
to the United States and your first trip
is president by coming here and honoring
us with these remarks and bringing your
your cabinet with you and we look
forward to many many more occasions to
to welcome you here mr. president muchas
gracias de vuelta muchisima gracias
thank you very much to each one of you
and tell you mr. Sachs that a few days
ago after many years impaired ago we
made a secretary of young people mr.
Polanco's the minister I don't want to
lead the US without bringing a good
piece of news to my young people because
the government is going to have an
important participation but I want the
government also offered scholarships to
the most prepared and trained people in
there who can have the possibility of
forming themselves studying in informing
themselves so in postgraduate studies in
here in Colombia they're gonna ask me
you were there mr. president would you
bring back I don't want to return with
my hands empty I promised my young
people that I was going to make a big
commitment to them and especially in
their preparation of formation
thank you don't thank me I'm the one who
should give you things for allowing me
to be here beloved young people you
motivate me a lot just with your energy
when I see young people with questions
interested in wanting to go forward the
world is says you're the engine leak out
for the world use the experience always
of those who know more but you're going
to be the force the life force in the
future and I really appreciate this so
much and hopefully we have countrymen
over here and we'll maintain our
communication that this not be the only
time that we maintain the relationships
that we can exchange relationships and
we can exchange ideas and about our
successes and our failures and our
mistakes sometimes we learn the best or
the most when we make a mistake if we at
some point we make a mistake you'll see
that we will be asking people to forgive
us and will rectify our errors I would
like to continue being available to you
for anything you know you need and thank
you for this wonderful opportunity